I want to let you know today that
there's an increasingly desperate
caravan of people who have decided they
simply cannot stay in their home
countries anymore
economic conditions and the sort of
realities on the ground are pushing them
across the border once and for all
from the United States into Canada where
they can find cheaper healthcare and
cheaper medications than in the United
States there was a story some months ago
I did about a daily caravan of Americans
that crosses the southern border into
Mexico for inexpensive but good quality
dentistry in Mexico and I think also it
was optometry in addition to dentistry
and there's a new report this week in
Newsweek about a so called Caravan and
I'm using the term sort of satirically
people Americans who are crossing into
Canada looking for more affordable
health care for type 1 diabetes because
the same drugs that are used to treat
diabetes in the United States are used
in Canada and they're much cheaper in
Canada insulin can be purchased in
Canada for about 10 percent of what it
costs in the United States and as some
of you know since the mid-90s the price
of insulin has increased more than 1,100
percent according to data from truven
health analytics but as you also
probably know wages have not increased
1,100 percent since the mid 90s and this
is of course in addition to what most
people are paying kind of in total for
their health care which is health
insurance premiums and co-pays and
uncovered medical expenses etc etc now
the FDA is officially taking the
position that it is risky to travel
outside the United States for insulin
because the safety of the insulin might
be compromised the effectiveness of
foreign insulin might not be as high and
of course that could apply to some
countries but in Canada it's fine and
this is just a truly horrible reality
and an optional problem of the system
that we have right the profit motive and
the political impasse has fixed this
issue
and it prevents us from actually dealing
with it and it's merely a decision we
have to make I mean we we know exactly
how this can be dealt with these are
relatively simple math problems
actuarial problems and mostly questions
of political will and I guess this is a
good opportunity I mean while we're at
it I should dispel the notion that
healthcare around the world is terrible
and unreliable and dangerous it's not
exactly what the FDA is saying when they
say you should have gotta be really
careful
if you go anywhere else for insulin
obviously there are many places in the
world where I would try to avoid having
to get health care services if traveling
or whatever the case may be but there
are so many countries even countries
considered so-called third world or
developing countries often have very
good health coverage at very very
reasonable rates Belize is an example
Belize has plenty of problems the
national income is about eight thousand
PPP dollars purchasing power parity
dollars so we don't even have to get to
what that means just think about eight
thousand US dollars is the sort of
national income per person it's not a
rich country but care is very good and
many Americans retire in bellies
partially because they can get good
cheap health care Argentina my home
country riddled with problems I mean
NASA economic problems but at private
hospitals and private clinics where you
would be paying for care as a visiting
American it is extraordinarily cheap by
our standards and you still get good
care some of the public hospitals in
Argentina particularly outside of the
capital city not the best but for what
we're used to paying going to private
hospitals in Argentina would be very
accessible and very good even in Mexico
Mexico is of interest more and more for
Americans to retire to and for medical
tourism and a lot of websites now are
solely dedicated to how can you legally
get resident status in Mexico it's of
course very stratified between regions
in Mexico in terms of what is available
but really excellent hospitals and care
many parts of the country including
Mexico City so in any case the American
economy would be better off if Americans
didn't feel the need to go to other
countries for care because you'd be
keeping those dollars here you'd be
funding people's salaries here in the
United States fortunately for us Mexico
and Canada are welcoming to people from
other countries who come from countries
that have third-world health insurance
systems like we have in the United
States and we know how to fix it
okay we have plans for how it can be
done we know what it would cost
but we remain stuck in this decades-long
I mean it's really like a century long
impasse which dates back to the period
between World War 1 and World War 2
where we were starting to go in the
direction of a more European model on
health care and then that idea was
smeared as being too much like Germany
at a time when we weren't getting along
with Germany for good reasons by the way
and it's been downhill ever since and
you know where we are today in 2019 but
at least Canada is there for type 1
diabetes sufferers to go and get
inexpensive and still reliable quality
insulin